vous êtes en fin de car 3 ans et je me
suis fait virer de l'église parce que je
sentais Étienne Étienne sur l'hôtel
c'est pas passé
j'arrive au bonsoir
alors j'arrive vous êtes que l'on
appelle la télé donc un bon client on
vous a du chien Arthur vos passages dans
Star sous hypnose son culte vous dites
d'ailleurs cette émission a changé ma
vie c'est vrai que Messmer vous a fait
tomber amoureux de Lara Fabian c'est
vrai vous avez déclaré ça serait une
bonne mère pour mes enfants Lara Fabian
il est fort ce Messmer non franchement
j'y croyais pas quand on m'a proposé
l'émission j'ai dit moi tout ce qui est
voyant et tout ça je crois pas et
vraiment il m'a pris totalement je suis
rentré dans le jeu et vraiment j'ai eu
des sentiments pour Lara Fabian pendant
un mois il a dû revenir pour vous
désenvoûter tu y crois Patrick il faut
pas qu'il s'approche de moi l'autre là
j'aime pas ces trucs
[Rires]
dans lequel tu étais tu mets du temps à
atterrir quand même
Lara Fabian
Véronique Sanson
je suis curieux j'ai pas voulu je
rappelle que la famille ne compte pas
[Rires]
[Musique]
bon alors on vous a dit donc chez Arthur
dans Vendredi tout est permis chez
Stéphane Bern donc comment ça va bien et
là alors votre texte était relu par le
comptable exactement ouais j'ai jamais
compris pourquoi ils avaient tellement
peur de ce que je pouvais faire il était
pas drôle et à chaque fois ça tu peux
pas ça passera pas et du coup au bout
d'un moment je lui ai dit d'aller se
faire parce que ça me saoulait et
à la compta et exactement non non mais
je leur donnais pas les bons textes en
fait je leur dis regarde c'est ça ça te
plaît c'est gentil et tout ça et après
je joins n'importe quoi en plateau et on
me coupait au montage
alors on vous a vu dans le grand musique
quiz dans l'académie des neufs dans mot
de passe dans Touche pas à mon poste
dans le plus grand cabaret du monde en
face à la bande dans action ou vérité
dans un full à poule il y a que le jour
du Seigneur vous avez pas fait encore et
pourtant j'étais en fin de carreir 3 ans
et je me suis fait virer de l'église
parce que je sentais Étienne Étienne sur
l'hôtel
c'est pas passé
vous êtes là maintenant nos solitaire on
en profite pour vous dire que vous avez
un vrai métier et vous serez donc sur la
scène de Bobino avec votre spectacle
atypique à partir du 19 décembre plus
tourné plus DVD oui
en fait j'ai tout le temps en spectacle
même quand vous êtes tout seul
depuis que je suis tout petit j'ai
toujours été seul donc je me suis
inventé des trucs voilà
là normalement bah si tu es censé me
défoncer après l'émission
[Rires]
mais non mais moi j'avais trois frères
qui étaient très différents de moi qui
était passionné par le foot la chasse et
tout et moi j'étais dans ma chambre et
je jouais ici l'impératrice avec ma
couette et je m'entraînais à mourir
devant la glace donc j'étais dans ma
tête il y avait que moi je fais le pitch
du spectacle donc vous faites la queue
au Pôle Emploi
nous raconter différentes expériences
professionnelles policiers majorette
caissier prêtre et là il y a la vanne
qui tue donc le prêtre lui dit
mettez-vous à genoux et lui il lui dit
vous voulez pas compris d'abord
ça j'adore cette vanne elle est
indépassable et pourtant je catholique
vous voyez mais ça me fait rire et c'est
pas du tout passé
alors atypique c'est à la fois du
stand-up du chant de la danse du mime
enfin faites votre numéro quoi
de moi et les voisins venaient voir ma
mère en disant il est pas comme ses
frères il a typique lui alors il y a un
truc très drôle qui s'est passé un soir
vous avez vu une femme voilée qui était
au deuxième rang et vous lui excusez-moi
madame je vais vous poser la question
tout le monde se pose est-ce que vous
avez une ceinture d'explosif sur vous
j'adore parce que je pense qu'on peut
rire de tout et voilà qui ne rira pas
exactement on va parler de vous
[Musique]
venez de rappeler sur Lyon
de 600 habitants voilà vous êtes né
prématurément le 5 août 1977 suite à un
accident de voiture ma mère est sortie
de la voiture et le mec en face la dit
tais-toi grosse vache et là je me suis
vénère à l'intérieur voilà laisse-moi
passer et vous êtes né alors famille qui
ont rien à voir avec le spectacle dans
le côté c'est des fondeurs de l'autre
côté c'est des viticulteurs voilà
ambiance plutôt chasse pêche tradition
chez vous
on est des bonhommes quoi
j'ai tellement différent de votre
famille que vous demandez si vous avez
pas été échangé à la naissance en fait
j'ai même fait des recherches j'ai pensé
pendant des années que j'avais été
adopté parce que je me disais c'est pas
possible il y a un truc à un moment
donné qui fait que pendant que mes
frères vont à la chasse moi je vais
vendre des œufs sur le marché pour
m'acheter une Barbie il y a un truc même
mais
franchement tu es chelou et moi je
savais pas ce qu'il y avait à
l'intérieur et après
toujours alors j'imagine que vous n'avez
jamais eu à faire de coming out quand
vous avez approché vos parents et vous
en dit oui on sait non ah non parce
qu'en plus mon père disait tout le temps
à table si un jour j'ai un effet SPD je
mets une cartouche
[Rires]
mais même moi je ne me savais pas moi
j'ai régulièrement fait l'amour à des
femmes j'étais pas convaincue par le
projet mais je me suis entêté jusqu'à 24
ans et à 24 ans j'ai couché avec le
frère de la femme que je devais épouser
ah mais c'est vrai je crois que ça c'est
vraiment vrai elle me dit on devait se
marier une semaine après elle me dit à
mon frère qui est légionnaire qui qui
peut venir à nos fiançailles je dis bah
écoute il a qu'à rester dormir à la
maison je me lève à 3h du matin pour
faire pipi et bim
vous dites j'en suis fier parce que si
la vie choisissa pour moi c'est qu'il y
a un sens à tout ça ouais parce que je
crois que c'est tellement difficile
aujourd'hui d'être heureux d'être soi
voilà moi c'est pas un choix que j'ai
fait je suis né comme ça j'en suis
vraiment fier même si voilà on me charit
et puis bon c'est vrai que c'était très
efféminé quand même mais j'aime ce
défaut comment tu as perdu
[Rires]
comment je suis fière parce que je pense
qu'on vit qu'une fois autant vivre à
fond et puis il est con et ben qu'ils
aillent se faire
il y a des gens qui s'en aperçoivent pas
ouais il y a des fois je me fais draguer
par des femmes je me dis mais qu'est-ce
qu'elle ne voit pas
de votre Père qui est formidable avant
de mourir et vous a dit surtout vie
mais je suis surpris que vous sachiez ça
j'ai eu la chance ouais d'accompagner
mon papa jusqu'à la fin et comme c'était
un homme avec qui je m'endors pas du
tout et qui a toujours dit et quand on
appelait à la maison j'ai pas de fils
qui s'appelle Jarry
dernière minute de sa vie m'a dit
vraiment ce mot il m'a dit vie
c'est bien non bah ça fait du bien je
suis né à ce moment là je pense
l'histoire sur ton père va peut-être
faire son son chemin et il y a plein de
pairs qui vont se dire j'ai peut-être un
truc à dire à mon fils homo avant de
partir
tu reçois beaucoup de courrier il y a
beaucoup de
voir mon spectacle et qui me disent
écoutez on a mis notre enfant à la rue à
3 ans et en vous voyant aussi heureux
aussi bien dans votre peau je pense
qu'on a fait une connerie vous allez
vous marier
c'est pas parce que moi perso à la vie
en fait un peu comme un
saladier de fruits j'ai envie de goûter
tous les fruits
viendra
[Musique]
on
s'aimera comme j'ai demandé ce soir de
faire une petite critique après chaque
interview vous êtes trouvé comment là je
sais pas je calcule pas je suis hyper
impressionné parce que vraiment Pierre
Palmade pour moi c'est vraiment la reine
mère c'est la référence
la reine mère non mais vraiment quand
j'étais petit je le voyais dans ma télé
je me disais mais je me sens proche de
ce monsieur et quand je l'ai rencontré
pour la première fois j'étais tout
tremblant oui pour d'autres raisons
et pour être sûr de ne rien rater de
innarditude abonnez-vous et mettez un
pouce bleu